thousands of new york city firefighters
responded to the world trade center on 9
11.
343 would lose their lives
one was the brother of retired new york
city fire chief joseph pfeiffer who was
the first fire chief on the scene that
day remarkably that day he was being
filmed by a documentary crew shooting a
film about firefighters in lower
manhattan out on a report of a suspected
gas leak the group watched the first
plane hit the world trade center the
chief and the crew immediately raced to
the scene and soon entered the north
tower's lobby setting up a command
center and attempted to take control of
the situation he is telling his story of
that day in a new book ordinary heroes a
memoir of
9 11.
chief pfeiffer good morning
it's so good to see you again
same here um i wonder what is going
through your mind this morning
this morning 20 years after
it is an emotional morning for me
because i remember what i was doing that
day and i remember the faces
of my firefighters coming into the lobby
of the north tower
and you had to send them up including
your brother
i did
they came in quietly
and firefighters are never quiet
um but they had a grim look on their
face because
they knew
they were going to a dangerous
matter of fact the most dangerous fire
of their lives
you were the first chief on the scene
you were in charge and i'm just
wondering
how you
switch gears so quickly um you were
going to a routine gas leak and and to
the point you write
i could not think my way out of this
situation
i had to trust my instincts
initially i trust my instinct and and
when i saw the plane
hit the world trade center
i got on the radio
and and and said that the plane just
crashed into the building
but then i had to take
about 60 seconds to what i call
deliberate thinking
what do i need to do now and i got back
on the radio and this time i said
we have a number of floors on fire
and that the plane was aiming for the
building
jeff mentioned you sent firefighters up
as you would at any scene and your
brother was among them i was taken in
the book that you wrote about
how afterwards that documentary film
crew that was with you they had a shot
of you
telling kevin to take his company up
engine 33 to go up into that stairwell
what did it mean to you though to be
able to see that moment
that's a special moment it was a moment
where my brother came in and
he didn't say a word
and we looked at each other wondering if
we were going to be okay
and then i ordered him to go up
and as he turned around
[Music]
and took his firefighters which
jules was able to to get in the film
that was the last time i i saw my
brother kevin and engine 33. and like
it would never be easy there's no way to
get over this in an easy way
but in seeing the look on his face and
knowing he was there to do the job the
same way you were
did that help in the process of trying
to mourn your brother
it did
this was just a special moment we had
and to have it on film
really really helped
and
and so many firefighters we had their
the picture
that day i i think jules said something
like
67 or 69 we were he was able to capture
and it was and it was his job and so
many others job and then the book is
called ordinary heroes what what is an
ordinary hero to you
to me that day
as the firefighters were going up people
were coming down
and they said don't stop keep going you
can make it out of here
and we know from those survivors
that those simple words
made a difference
and when my brother
when i ordered
the firefighters in the north tower
to evacuate
as my brother was coming down
he stopped on the ninth floor and
redirected people and firefighters to a
safer way out
ordinary things
but in an extraordinary time
and that's my definition
of ordinary heroes
you you retired in 2018
but you've helped
the fire department rebuild and you've
helped in so many other ways
how are we better prepared today than we
were
20 years ago
today
we're working together
i spent a lot of time
working with nypd
and we brought nypd and fdny
together
and and not only to do exercises and
planning
but i'll tell you the secret
the secret was
taken from jules's grandmother
and that's
you have to feed them sit down for a
meal that's right and cook it yeah so
before or after every meeting and we
didn't have a headquarters we had my
center for terrorism and disaster
preparedness overlooking uh bayside bay
we we gave them a good firehouse meal
and whenever you share bread together
with your your colleagues you become
friends and willing to risk your life
for one another and that improved
communication was key you talk about
things that you wish you had known from
the police that day the communication
that's improved now there's one thing
i've heard over the last several days
and i'm curious as to your reaction
people say
time heals all wounds
with 911
does that still hold true
there's there's a process we go through
and we we see it when
groups gather in the street
at
they make their own memorial of candles
and flowers and pictures
because we want to be together
and then we tell stories
like we're doing here
but then we look to the future and we
envision a better way of doing it
and that's what we did with new york
city
how do we respond better and that
becomes at least for me became a new
purpose
of my life
and that that's part of the healing and
that's part of the book it is ordinary
heroes we thank you so much chief
pfeiffer for your time with us this
morning
thank you good to be with you best of
luck